do you really
bear the responsibility of the course of
our country based on a conversation i
think you can
revitalize and rehabilitate someone's
image
in a way that is pretty shocking look at
the way people look at alex jones now
because alex jones has been on my
podcast a few times yeah how do they
which direction the people that have
watched those podcasts think he's
hilarious
and they think that he definitely [ __ ]
up with that whole sandy hook thing
um but
he's right more than he's wrong
and
he's not an evil guy he's just a guy
who's had some psychotic breaks in his
life he's had some genuine mental health
issues that he's addressed he's had some
serious bouts of alcoholism some serious
bouts of you know substance abuse and
they've contributed to some very poor
thinking
but if you know the guy if you get to
know him like i have i've known him for
more than 20 years and if you know him
on podcasts you realize like
he is genuinely trying to unearth some
things that are genuinely disturbing for
most people like is the guy that was
telling me about
epstein's uh island
[ __ ] decade ago at least he was
telling me about i was like what you're
telling me there's a place
where they bring elites
to compromise them with underage girls
and they film them really like what cut
the [ __ ] out of here like no president
clinton's been there everyone's been
there like but it sounds like nonsense
and not only is it true but people keep
getting [ __ ] murdered for it did you
see that latest clinton advisor that got
murdered about it yep yeah hung with an
extension cord shot himself in the chest
30 miles from his house and they're
calling it a suicide and now even elon
musk is asking where's the clientele
list yeah we should we should probably
see who's been to that island yeah we
should probably see who's been to that
island
and there's probably more of those kind
of things out there that haven't been
exposed
yeah but sort of
uh to push back
in you you had those conversations with
alex jones wouldn't you be able to have
the same kind of conversation with
donald trump what's the problem reveal
no it's not the problem you revealed
that alex jones is a human being he's
[ __ ] up he has demons in his head he's
obviously chaotic all over the place but
there's some
uh
wisdom to the perspective he takes on
the world even if though he is often
full of [ __ ] he is able to predict
certain things and very few people are
willing to bring up
you